though Robert had risked all our lives
to win it the Iron Throne bored him he
cared little for justice and less for
rule if it weren't women or wine skinny
had no use for it without the stalwart
John Aaron as hand of the king the
challenge to Robert's crown would have
come much earlier than it did the Iron
Islands have never lacked for treachery
they respect only strength and honor is
as foreign to them as the seven after
six years their ruler Lord Balin Greyjoy
weighted that King Robert had not won
the support of the Great Houses of
Westeros
many of whom still named him user / Lord
Balin declared the Iron Islands
independent and sent his iron fleet to
Lannisport Lord Tywin Lannister was
careless and the Ironborn caught and
burnt his ships at anchor Lord Balin and
his Reavers controlled the sunset sea
Robert then ordered me to succeed where
his father-in-law Lord Tywin had failed
beneath robert's fury I sensed relief
war he could understand he would smash
Lord Balin as he had Rhaegar I raised
Roberts fleet and sailed around Westeros
to the Iron Islands I set a trap for the
iron fleet of fair isle as sailors and
warriors the Ironborn are unparalleled
but they're not soldiers they have no
discipline no strategy no unity in a
battle each man fights only for his own
glory and their longships are built for
lightning strikes and Shore raids when
the captain's rushed in I smashed their
longships with our larger war galleys
the strength of the Ironborn is in their
ships with the iron fleet broken
I had assured Roberts victory he could
now transport troops and siege weapons
to invade the Iron Islands and contrary
to baylin's hopes Robert had plenty of
both I've never seen such allegiances
Robert could inspire in war enemies who
tried to kill him one day would be
drinking within the next under their own
fallen banners in rebelling against the
Iron Throne Lord Balin did more than
Robert ever could to cement his rule
when Robert came to the Iron Islands he
brought with him the full power of
Westeros sir Barristan Selmy of the
Kingsguard led the assault on old wick
while I subdued great wick the largest
of the Iron Islands but Robert saved the
seat of house Greyjoy pike for himself
and Lord Eddard Robert would later boast
of the battles bloodiness and how he
could have torn down the island into the
waves if Lord Balin hadn't bent the knee
but if I'd have led the assault
baylin's net would have bent under his
sword because I do not forget I do not
pardon his time will come all their
times will come